- [Instructor] In this video,
we're going to introduce
ourselves to the idea
of partial pressure due to ideal gases.
And the way to think about it is
imagine some type of a container,
and you don't just have one
type of gas in that container.
You have more than one type of gas.
So let's say you have gas one
that is in this white color.
And obviously, I'm not
drawing it to scale,
and I'm just drawing those
gas molecules moving around.
You have gas two in this yellow color.
You have gas three in this blue color.
It turns out that people
have been able to observe
that the total pressure in this system
and you could imagine that's being exerted
on the inside of the wall,
or if you put anything in this container,
the pressure, the force per
area that would be exerted
on that thing is equal to the sum
of the pressures contributed
from each of these gases
or the pressure that each
gas would exert on its own.
So this is going to be equal to
the partial pressure due to gas one
plus the partial pressure due to gas two
plus the partial pressure
due to gas three.
And this makes sense mathematically
from the ideal gas law
that we have seen before.
Remember, the ideal gas law tells us
that pressure times volume is
equal to the number of moles
times the ideal gas constant
times the temperature.
And so if you were to
solve for pressure here,
just divide both sides by volume.
You'd get pressure is equal to nR
times T over volume.
And so we can express both
sides of this equation that way.
Our total pressure, that would
be our total number of moles.
So let me write it this way, n total
times the ideal gas constant
times our temperature in kelvin
divided by the volume of our container.
And that's going to be equal to,
so the pressure due to gas one,
that's going to be the
number of moles of gas one,
times the ideal gas constant
times the temperature,
the temperature is not going
to be different for each gas,
we're assuming they're all
in the same environment,
divided by the volume.
And once again, the volume
is going to be the same.
They're all in the same
container in this situation.
And then we would add that to
the number of moles of gas two
times the ideal gas constant,
which once again is going
to be the same for all of the gases,
times the temperature
divided by the volume.
And then to that,
we could add the number
of moles of gas three
times the ideal gas constant
times the temperature
divided by the volume.
Now, I just happen to
have three gases here,
but you could clearly keep going
and keep adding more
gases into this container.
But when you look at it
mathematically like this,
you can see that the right-hand side,
we can factor out the RT over V.
And if you do that, you
are going to get n one
plus n two
plus n three,
let me close those parentheses, times RT,
RT over V.
And this right over here
is the exact same thing
as our total number of moles.
If you say the number of moles of gas one
plus the number of moles of gas two
plus the number of moles of gas three,
that's going to give you
the total number of moles
of gas that you have in the container.
So this makes sense
mathematically and logically.
And we can use these mathematical ideas
to answer other questions
or to come up with other
ways of thinking about it.
For example, let's say that we knew
that the total pressure in our container
due to all of the gases
is four atmospheres.
And let's say we know that
the total number of moles
in the container is equal to
eight moles.
And let's say we know
that the number of moles of gas three
is equal to two moles.
Can we use this information to figure out
what is going to be the partial
pressure due to gas three?
Pause this video, and
try to think about that.
Well, one way you could think about it is
the partial pressure due to gas three
over the total pressure,
over the total pressure
is going to be equal to,
if we just look at this
piece right over here,
it's going to be this.
It's going to be the number
of moles of gas three
times the ideal gas constant
times the temperature
divided by the volume.
And then the total pressure,
well, that's just going
to be this expression.
So the total number of moles
times the ideal gas constant
times that same temperature,
'cause they're all in
the same environment,
divided by that same volume.
They're in the same container.
And you can see very clearly
that the RT over V is
in the numerator and the denominator,
so they're going to cancel out.
And we get this idea that the,
I'll write it down here,
the partial pressure due to gas three over
the total pressure
is equal to
the number of moles of gas three
divided by the total,
total number of moles.
And this quantity right over here,
this is known as the mole fraction.
Let me just write that down.
It's a useful concept.
And you can see the mole
fraction can help you figure out
what the partial pressure is going to be.
So for this example, if we
just substitute the numbers,
we know that the total pressure is four.
We know that the total
number of moles is eight.
We know that the moles,
the number of moles of gas three is two.
And then we can just solve.
We get, let me just do
it, write it over here,
I'll write it in one color,
that the partial pressure
due to gas three over four
is equal to two over
eight, is equal to 1/4.
And so you can just pattern match this,
or you can multiply both sides by four
to figure out that the partial
pressure due to gas three
is going to be one.
And since we were dealing
with units of atmosphere
for the total pressure, this
is going to be one atmosphere.
And we'd be done.